what's happening you bad [ __ ]
it's monday
march the 1st it's a whole new [ __ ]
set of rules
greetings from the joint the joint is
brought to you by
number one movement watches but first i
got a little story for you
in a tiny apartment in southern
california two guys revolutionized the
watch business
a couple of college dropouts came in and
shook things up
fair prices new colors fresh designs and
now
movement is an international brand
way more than just watches they've been
expanding into blue light glasses
jewelry and more let me tell you
something the glasses they sent me
are tremendous for the computer or for
when i'm in the car driving i love them
i look like a [ __ ] professor it makes
me look smart
but besides that the watch they sent me
the watch the element international
waters
because i'm an international man of
mystery is also tremendous
these movement watches are smart that
pieces look like they cost a half a
stack
but since they own the process and do
everything online
you end up paying a fraction of what
they would charge you in a department
store so do me a favor
you got no middleman movement passes
that quality on to you
ships free and if you don't love it send
it back
and it's all for free it's all forgotten
elevate your look today
but don't break the bank join the
movement and get
15 off today 15 off
with free shipping and free returns by
going to
mbmt.com joey again
it's movement watches but for now for
the website it's
mbmt.com
joey you're showing up with nothing but
heart and a movement watch you
understand me
they're beautiful they're rugged i love
them
the chair ah the church the joint is
also brought to you by
my favorite company in the world on it
listen when it comes to supplements
on it's got you whether it's the shroom
tech whether it's the alpha brain
whether it's the new mood the the shri
the alpha brain powder that you put into
your little
six eight ounces of water and shake it
up they've got the
the new snacks the uh the uh the chips
the spicy cheddar and i also just put a
video up
for uh the chocolate peanut butter cups
like that
it's not a chocolate peanut butter cup
it's like chocolate with peanut butter
in it
but there's seven grams of protein they
call them like protein bites
listen i love honor as a company i love
what they provide i love what they do
their service you know alpha brain you
get alpha brain you don't like it
which is that flagship product if it
doesn't work for you
you tell them they'll send you the money
back and you can keep the product
that's a company that's a company that
cares
that's why i do business without it so
go to honor.com right now and press in
church
c-h-u-r-c-h and get 10 off
your first order that's it and that's
that it's monday
the 1st of march let's get this party
[Music]
started
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what's happening you bad [ __ ]
monday morning
march 1st can you believe it's [ __ ]
march 1st and like
10 days is gonna be when the [ __ ]
pandemic shut everything down
saint patty's day so we're a year away
so this cost us a year of our lives
but we did it we're almost there that
said it's springtime and [ __ ] 21 days
or some [ __ ]
we [ __ ] did it out of the celebration
i wore my little light blue because it's
monday
i want to come out looking good i got my
little head dude
done everything's good i'm off the
[ __ ] pain pills
they [ __ ] narrowed me down the viking
and on monday i didn't take a viking
until wednesday
i got a little [ __ ] up on thursday i'm
like that's it i'm done
that's bike i'm only good with viking
for like two days that's it
after that i can't deal with it no more
but we [ __ ]
uh passed on from the oxies everybody's
okay everybody's alive and kicking
and we're here for another fun monday
for the last couple weeks
uh ever since i left l.a i've been
thinking about him
and i've been talking a lot about him on
the podcast because
i hadn't seen him in years um
but i didn't realize that i got to new
jersey and
unwind and everything yes rogan helped
me a lot in comedy ralph he helped me a
lot in comedy you know mitzi sure helped
me
i had a lot of help in comedy but one of
the guys that gave me the biggest boost
ever a boost is like in the street of
boosters if i went up to mike and gave
him five grand
you know how would you feel you feel
like a brand new man the first person
to really give me a boost in comedy was
doug stanhope i've said that a thousand
times
i met him in 91 92 he did the broken
joker once or twice
uh he slept over one time you know he
gave me advice and then i didn't
talk to him for a long time and then uh
i bumped into them in seattle in 95 96
i did new years of them in 97 96 i think
we did new year's together
and the rest was history he uh he pumped
me up man he built me up
and uh he said great things to me he
held my confidence
and it was him who gave me the push to
actually
get the balls to [ __ ] move to la
because if it was up to me i was scared
you know i was like i was not
nothing was ever going to happen i was
so [ __ ] negative
you know between the drugs and you know
my past i didn't think i could move
forward
past that and he was like a [ __ ]
brother to me
i lived with him i stayed with him uh he
you know he called the comedy
store for me and gave me a reference so
as far as i'm concerned he's uh he's one
of my mentors he's one of my best
friends
he's one of my brothers so what we did
this weekend is you've had enough of me
you've had enough of me i've had enough
of me i'm sick of [ __ ] talking
i did i did a [ __ ] zoom over the
weekend with uh doug
stanhope and uh i hope you enjoy it
that's all i can tell you
i'll check in with yous afterwards thank
you for coming on and watching
enjoy this doug what's happening when
you left l.a was the end
and i didn't even realize that at that
time
that was yeah that seems like when it
started
yeah it was just [ __ ] it's good that
uh
i get to see you live in a [ __ ]
person finally
you look good there we go yeah we're on
one all right good
yeah no it's it seemed like l.a started
when i left that's when the comedy store
became
booming and yeah but
then it just grew into something else i
think
you were you had everybody on shakedown
you you had everybody
everybody was checked when you were in
town once you left
the checking went away they they all got
cocky and you know
everybody started driving lamborghinis
and comic and [ __ ]
it was just too much man how are you
doing down there
uh beautiful i i love doing nothing i
love being at home
i don't miss comedy uh so yeah i get the
perfect setup for
as a shut-in down here why don't you
miss comedy doug
oh it's [ __ ] just at the constant
headache of
trying to come up with new [ __ ] right
that cycle of going out you know every
two years going i [ __ ] got nothing i
have no interest i have no you know
there's nothing in my life or in the
news that i care to [ __ ]
rail about and uh i'll never be funny
again and then you get
the one thing you go oh [ __ ] i can't
wait to do this on stage
so right now i don't have that one thing
but
i've been getting on stage once a week
and i i enjoy it when i'm doing it but i
don't really want to do it
it's the craziest thing i'm not looking
to travel
i'm not looking to do dick yeah i saw
ellen
arrogan tweeted a picture of her flying
in or out of philly
and she's in a plane with a mask on and
then one of the plastic
shields in front of the mask you know
like i said
no i i like flying to [ __ ] get drunk
in first class i don't
want to be pulling down a mask and
sipping and
then i get the smoker's cough which is
going to have four rows on either side
staring back at me how you doing with
the non-smoking
that failed quickly [ __ ] it you quit
10 days all right guys like what you're
talking about as
i was just listening to episode 41 where
you talked about how to quit
doing coke 10 000 times before it gets
stuck so yeah yeah
ten thousand i wake up in the morning
yeah i wake up in the morning
yeah i won't smoke till like after yeah
the day is done and happy hour cocktails
and then the more i'm determined to quit
that day the more i'm
thinking about smoking and the earlier i
start because i'm thinking about
quitting too much
and then i'm thinking about smoking when
it's in your head like that you can't
quit you just that's the way the cocaine
was in my head
like i just heard the more i wanted to
quit
i would quit and then call the guy 10
minutes later
like what the [ __ ] am i doing i just
quit doing coke
and then i would call the guy in my mind
you know so are you saying that you're
not going to go on the road anymore
no no i get dates but not till august
and uh yeah
i'll get the vaccine i'll be the last
guy to get the vaccine right before i
get on a plane
uh
i'm enjoying doing nothing i have not
slept in my own bed
for an entire year since i was 17 years
old
like to actually just be at your house
for a [ __ ] year
is i mean it's i might as well be
you know move to a [ __ ] south
american country
changing your life that much knowing
where your [ __ ] is
hey they're on the spice rack right next
to the [ __ ] tony
satcheries and the uh salt and pepper
like i know that now when
when's the last time you knew where all
your [ __ ] was and you just moved to
jersey
so like you you you have a brand new
place you know where all your [ __ ] is
when's the last time that happened
no it's [ __ ] crazy it's i can't even
see myself
going to the airport i think i would
have an anxiety attack as soon as i
walked into the [ __ ] airport
i would drop right on the floor from a
panic attack
that and just everyone else's levels of
rage would put me into a level of rage
that's the other thing see my big thing
isn't the culvert
as much as getting on a plane in burbank
at one in the afternoon
landing in vegas at 212
and i get a call that brody's dead
now let's play this a different way you
go to arizona
you get on a plane you're going up to
boston you get the 6 a.m flight
when you land in boston four white cops
shot two guys the night before
now and they're briding two blocks from
the comedy club
[ __ ] you know do you need this in your
life doug
no no i don't and this is where i'm
coming from i'm
i'm not in love with comedy anymore like
i did what
if i'm going on 30 years you're going on
31
at 32. 31 31 in uh
august yeah because i met you at the
broker
in 91 you came in as a feature act
and then in 92 yeah
you got evening at the improv and you
became a headliner
next time i saw you i i i i just wanted
to say like
you don't have people to send you an
email or a tweet going hey they were
talking about you on this podcast
and you'd go listen to the podcast to
hear your name i
get old
someone's whole podcast just to hear my
name and then at that point i don't even
need to hear my name but anytime someone
sends me you talking about me
i always [ __ ] listen because you
you you you make first of all you're
always [ __ ] make me sound
great and uh but your your facts are
always [ __ ] up i'm always yelling at
my
oh no that was like 95 when you you said
it was 85 i was just
in high school i get high and i get
i get high and i get confused but i
started hosting
right now it was yeah it was probably
around uh 90
92 or 93 that i met you in boulder
you had to push me you had to push me
pull you uh
flew where you don't know which end to
[ __ ] aim at the toilet and which end
to aim at the trash can
yep i remember you slept over my house
one night because
the old colorado run was boulder
and then craig on thursday
remember you had went frozen
it did freeze up yeah if you did for a
second but yeah
it was the joker broker in boulder and i
remember that
and then you were off on thursdays on
wednesday
i was living out of my car at the time
and uh my license was
about to expire but in colorado they
gave it to you the same day
so i had a driver's license with the
address of the joker broker and the room
number as my apartment
for for years and then i had my friend
sell you a car
and you put oh yeah that dodge neon mike
kessler you put
you put his his address down as
a reference or some [ __ ] uncle mike
i remember that dodge neon because uh
shortly after i bought that my first cd
came out so i had a
trunk full of copies of my new cd and
someone broke into my car to steal a
change they smashed
the window to steal the change out of
the change dish but didn't take a single
one of my [ __ ] cds
that's crazy didn't your car get broken
into the night of the finals
at the san francisco comedy competition
your car always gets breaking into
the bad one because they stole all these
i everything i owned was in the car so
they stole
all my [ __ ] so i stand in there in this
thrift store suit
with a check for ten thousand dollars i
just won
and it's this piece of [ __ ] car with all
my belongings gone and i was
smiling from [ __ ] ear to ear i didn't
need that [ __ ]
that is crazy doug it has been a long
[ __ ] journey my friend that's the
other thing like i'm coming on 30 years
now i started as a doorman at wits end
and then i became like i got on stage at
the bro
at the comedy works and then
i got the the hosting gig at the broker
until 93.
so i'm like you i mean i've done
everything i wanted to do already in
comedy
right now i enjoy it just going on stage
for 30 people once a week
but i don't think i could do a whole
weekend at a comedy club anymore
yeah yeah the the traveling involved
the [ __ ] again i'll get back into it but
right now i'm really just happy to be
home
and you still own the whole block
and i know everyone on both blogs i
walked the dog
you know about eight blocks around and i
know
sammy and i know patrick and i know alex
and aaron and i know
sandy and sean and i so like i know all
my neighbors
i'm like my dad i wave i make a little
small talk about the weather and move
on i'm like you i still don't pick up
dog [ __ ] but i'm the nicest neighbor in
the world
i won't pick that [ __ ] up that's why i
won't get a [ __ ] dog [ __ ] that
i remember you yelling about that all
the time in l.a these [ __ ] people
picking up dog [ __ ]
who the [ __ ] does that leave them
where we live it's the [ __ ] desert so
there's packs of javelinas
so and there's [ __ ] deer and there's
you know you got rabbit [ __ ] you got cow
[ __ ] you got horse [ __ ] you got [ __ ]
wild pig
[ __ ] and i'm gonna clean up my dog [ __ ]
now
[ __ ] from everything out there well as a
dog special
now how far are you from phoenix or
civilization
uh about uh three and a half four hours
and you'll love it that is uh murphy
still down there with you morgan
morgan still rents a place down here so
uh she comes down she had that surgery
so
i haven't seen much of her in the last
year but
and is the comedy club still going down
there
yo yeah there you are
is the comedy club still going on down
there oh that's uh becker's place
yeah he he still has a bar over there uh
but uh they they do comedy here and
again
he couldn't [ __ ] he can't make a
comedy club work full-time in a
town of 5 000 people he had big dreams
but
i mean if you have a bar you're gonna
have customers down here so
yeah he's doing all right that's a big
drinking area down there
yeah so what's the future of doug
stanhope like
after 30 years in comedy what do you
want to do now
i have no idea like i wish i wanted to
ask you about that when you switched up
uh you you turned it from uh
church of what's happening now to you
know joey's joint
were you just rebranding or was there a
reason you changed up
i want to start fresh i was moving to
jersey
you know i had a new co-host i wanted to
start fresh
you know that was the church that was in
la
you know that was a different whole
field i feel like a different person
since i left l.a
so i wanted for it to be have a
different feel of a podcast you know
yeah i wish when i started my podcast it
was just
dog [ __ ] podcasts and you know maybe i
should re-brand this if i hadn't taken
this seriously
since the beginning i could possibly
technical issues getting closer to the
router
yeah yeah why not why [ __ ] around the
wife and the kid
aren't going to be home for a while why
[ __ ] around you know what i'm saying
i might as well bring it right here to
my little bar
and [ __ ] it gorgeous
yeah this is coming down though
this bar is coming down because we're
not we're turning into a family room
i'm not a boozer i don't have no booze
here i got a couple bottles of booze
but when i had knee surgery i had to
move down here
and me and my wife would look at this
place and go why do we even have this
bar
i was gonna do the podcast from here
originally but they could hear
everything upstairs so if my daughter's
home
she could hear me going off you know
so i didn't want her hearing me down
here you know [ __ ] you
suck my dick all that [ __ ] while she's
upstairs so
you know how it goes when you have an
eight-year-old you gotta
you gotta be at least a little cool you
know what i'm saying
yeah what were you talking about sorry
nothing just l.a and what the [ __ ]
happened like
you left when in 2005
yeah 2005 i was gone you know in 2007 i
stopped going to the store
and it was like you know ralphie was
running things ralphie was on the road
pretty [ __ ] heavy
i was thinking about quit and then the
podcast thing started
i started the podcast with felicia and
then i started selling tickets
but in 2010 i was just about to quit
comedy
i had had it i was like you know what
i'll do a movie from time to time
get my insurance and then uh
just do that but because of the podcast
this is why we're still here yeah that's
why i wished i'd put more effort into
the podcast
because you know you don't get a second
chance to uh
but that's why i was asking you about
rebranding because i i've thought about
like just starting a new one where you
go all right
people can get into this from [ __ ]
ground level and i'll actually put
effort into it because my if i knew how
happy
i would be being home i'd [ __ ]
podcast for a living
listen man just sit you know get a time
every week write whatever you want to do
and just sit there once a week and tell
your thoughts
if somebody comes down yeah i find it
interesting
have a guest if not just do it yourself
you're the one that i remember coming to
you one time and going doug
they want me to [ __ ] headline i don't
have the time you go just go up there
and talk [ __ ]
yeah well you can do that you're
naturally funny you're one of those guys
that could
can do that i have to write no
you can still you all you need is a
topic
a guy like you just needs a topic i just
gotta throw a topic
at you and you can rant on it for an
hour
yeah not necessarily not like you can
45 minutes you can i bet you can
i struggled but i had to work on it i
[ __ ] the reason why i went to one man
is because
a covered it's tough to get guests
and i would hate to give somebody covet
or for me to get cove
from somebody over a [ __ ] stupid
podcast
and b i really admired what bill burr
was doing
yeah you know bill bird just gets on
there on monday and thursday
and [ __ ] talk [ __ ] and keeps you
engaged
i tried to do that really when i first
started like i'm gonna try one just
build burst i'll do it by myself
alone and i felt completely [ __ ]
ridiculous
talking to myself i couldn't do it i
would never make it more than like three
minutes
where i go all right this is stupid i
need to at least have someone looking at
me
uh and then if they're looking at me
then i want them to talk back
but i i found it like this year i've
done like
i [ __ ] love the zoom thing except for
the occasional
technical [ __ ] quirks i i i've had
comics i don't even know i've done their
podcast they've done mine
and i i kind of like it i dig it like
before colvin i
like the hardest part is reaching
out and asking someone to be on your
podcast because that used to be the
thing
the [ __ ] drudgery of it was i don't
have to drive especially in l.a
i remember having it i did burst podcast
and then i had to go
do uh burke crisis podcast right after
that
and that's like an hour and ten minutes
in a [ __ ] uber
and yeah that's but now if someone's
just [ __ ] sitting around their house
with zoom
yeah i'll do podcasts oh it's kind of
cool i like
i'll tell you when i like zoom i like
zoom because i have a relationship with
you
and they could feel the relationship
through the zoom
if i don't know you the zoom is gonna
suck
okay it's like when when when i get
together with rogan yeah the podcast
does great
not because i'm the funniest guy in the
world but because i have chemistry with
him
exactly i've known him for 20 years the
same thing with you i put
i sit down with you in a room it's all
over but the shopping
it's all over but the [ __ ] shop we'll
just destroy them because it's both of
us
but while also
i can chain smoke without stinking up
rogan's studio
oh i love that every time you light a
cigarette rogan's [ __ ] hairs would
pop
up in the back of his neck i love when
you're on rogan i love it i love it
because every time you light a cigarette
he goes he just jumps
just by the sound of the lighter he
would just jump his soul would jump
but i did it you know i was talking to
rogan one day about it maybe about a
year ago
and we were talking about uh bill's
podcast and he said that he felt
that the reason bill got so strong
were those bits were because he did that
podcast by himself for an
hour and i started thinking about it and
i go if i'm going to make it back to com
because i didn't do stand up for seven
months
it was seven months without a [ __ ]
stage
and i did a couple spots when i moved to
jersey outside
almost got attacked by [ __ ] bats and
[ __ ] they got these outdoor shows
up against the marsh it's [ __ ] crazy
it's crazy but i'm excited about this
year because now i know the area and i
can do outdoor shows i know how to do
them you know
so because the covert we'd have we've
had to adjust in so many different
levels
i love doing the podcast by myself it
just builds up it's an
hour 45 minutes to an hour that you got
to pick a subject and talk about it
so instead of doing it in a notebook i
just do it on camera
what do you think yeah that was the the
worst part of uh
uh coven for at least the first several
months is because our podcast is just
usually us
talking [ __ ] about what we did that week
or what gig we just came back from or
you know what our friends do and then
once covet started it's just
same the three of us so what's new this
week
[ __ ] nothing we haven't done anything
yeah so
and i don't give a [ __ ] about what's
going on in the news and i'm not going
to talk about trump but
so yeah we just we'd have to make up
[ __ ] to talk about
you know doug you've had a life i mean
you've had a
you've got a couple books that you've
published
and you know you just we just go into
some of the stories
and that's a podcast you know the time
i'm a mean you in boston and we did that
comedy connection
that one club
and we had to do midnight radio you and
i they had a radio we had to do
after the show on a friday night it was
me you and chris mcguire i think
and we went to the radio show and that's
when i said to you
about the that's the time that was the
week that your mom's cat died
and she made like a little weight for
her she put them on little
box with a with a carpet on it or
something and all the other i think
i think that's in my first book yeah
joey
oh and all the other cats are sitting
around the dead cat
looking at it going i could use that eye
i need that leg
[Laughter]
i still miss your mother i still miss
her you nicknamed her
bonnie earmuffs
because you talk so [ __ ] much and uh
and not only did that nickname stick
until her death
but i've reused that for other chatty
kathy's and come over and i'm like oh
you can't take any more [ __ ]
stephanie earmuffs out there
i still remember the day you called me
up and said ralphie left the house
crying because you caught him again
he said that you caught him making out
with his mother do you remember that day
you called me and you're like
have you heard from ralphie you froze
out completely for that sentence
say it again you said that uh you called
me up one day and you said that
have i heard from ralphie and i go no
and you go yeah i caught him making out
with my mother
and i yelled at him and he took off and
i remember going over to your house and
you guys played a trick on me and [ __ ]
oh okay i was gonna say that didn't
happen that's another one of ralphie's
lies
no it wasn't ralphie was you who called
me yeah that's what i'm saying
i no i would remember
ralphie making out with my mother
ralphie spun a [ __ ]
uh a lot of a lot of yarns
uh he told some tall tales
i mean and we all loved them regardless
but
no he did my mother did jack off one of
her cats in front of ralphie so i
i did have a witness for that logan
that was a thing that just for like
shock value
no they like it i mean i don't think she
did it to completion
but if she got her cat splayed out with
his [ __ ] frog legs [ __ ]
nisa kimbo and his [ __ ] [ __ ] and ball
show she'd [ __ ]
tug his little [ __ ] cat package just
to
get a reaction it's [ __ ] crazy you
know
that they uh we had a great neighborhood
at that time it was yuan kirsan
nick depaolo and mitch hedberg on sierra
bonita
ralphie on curson no on uh schrader
yeah do you remember that girl which one
evan she was that blonde tall blonde
that was always
slept over the hot yeah
and the husband was bob yeah bob who's
yeah i
still see all the time he's doing a lot
of movies now
they shot somebody in front of bob's
house
oh no [ __ ] yeah they shot that lady
gaga's dog walker on sierra bonita
oh wow all right that was that was on
sierra bonito the other day
i know that where we used to live and
walk and talk and breathe and [ __ ]
walk around
and see the guy from uh
whatever [ __ ] that that crazy guy
from that show where they hurt
themselves
i used to see him going into 7-eleven
stevo
oh yeah i used to see stevo going into
that liquor store
on the corner of curson across the
street
oh yeah [ __ ] ralphie bay lived on
gardner
yep with uh jodie ferdig uh there was a
minute where celine hinojosa was there
uh
state of my house yeah
uh that same building where i lived on
curse on
hennigan was living there brett erickson
and carrie mitchell were living there
uh i guess they both still have
apartments there but uh yeah it was like
a whole comedy compound
after a while once the comedy store got
huge
and i [ __ ] loved i there was nothing
more exciting for me when the comedy
store
did get huge was to go back because it
was like
it was like going to the after party at
montreal there's that
that many comedians of that top level
all hanging out in that back bar with
kerry mitchell
and i just i would never do a set there
i would just go in and [ __ ]
treat it like a high school reunion i
remember
go ahead i'm sorry oh no i just i
remember
being there once when it was like at its
new you know
height and rogan coming out going you
have to move back here
it's a new renaissance comedy you have
to you have to move back you have to
move back now
you're missing all this i'm happy
visiting all this
it was too much man it really had become
too much
it wasn't even comedy anymore it was
like this [ __ ]
grandioso type deal i don't know what it
was
i miss it i was there i'm happy i was
there for 20 years
thank you for calling uh scott
for me and giving me a reference but it
was time to go doug
it's almost nicer that it it kind of
ended because of
covid rather than just figuring out
every other scene
now you can blame something now you can
blame a disease on it rather than
it just got too full of itself and
eventually no one gave a [ __ ]
yeah it was just and you know i think i
think comedy had just changed
how managers were sending
comics out and the way they were booking
them
it was just a greed fest man it was just
too much
and i got caught in the cycle of it and
i didn't like it i was like what the
[ __ ] is going on
with me that this is what i wanted to do
all my life
but i'm not happy doing it yeah
it was pretty overwhelming the whole
scene was overwhelming it was
overwhelming it was too much
and that's why we don't want to do it
anymore when you yeah when you get to a
certain age did you think
uh because i was like on the road
i don't i don't hang out after shows on
the road for the last several years
i mean i'll go back to the hotel bar and
drink with my tour manager and
you know my the other other comics that
are on the bill but i wouldn't go to
bars anymore it's just
that that the swell of people i
i don't have the attention span and i'm
always feeling
yeah about fans and like yeah i want to
say hi to all my fans and
but you know when there's like eight
people having a conversation
over each other at a merch booth and
it's [ __ ] exhausting that's
exhausting
that that and you always feel like you
didn't give them enough
like all right you need more than a show
you need a picture okay i get it i've
never been a picture guy
and i hate i don't know what to do with
my face in a picture
but i'll do it and then by the time that
that can last longer than your set
where you're just taking pictures and by
the time that's over i don't want to
[ __ ] talk to anyone
so yeah going to the comedy store where
i do want to say hi to all these people
i felt like you know the the cliche of
oh
he's looking over his shoulder to see
who else is more important
no i just have this many people i
haven't seen in 10 years
and i want to say hi to all of them in a
night uh so yeah that would it would get
a little uh
overbearing yes it did get a little it
got a little weird on the road i'm
really happy about coping in the sense
that
you don't have to take pictures no more
like it's just a [ __ ] comedy show
that's it it's just a comedy show you
know
uh the pictures was getting out of
control you know
women touching you guys grabbing you
it's like you know
i don't need this [ __ ] i enjoyed
the completion of the circle you know
doug they watch you special
they listen to your podcast then they
come see you live
we shake hands and that's a completion
of the circle
yeah that's what that's how social media
works and i enjoyed it
but you're right there's some people who
if you gave an inch to they want a mile
it wasn't enough you know you take a
picture with them
they come back as you're leaving i
didn't like the picture can we do it
again
can you call my cousin yeah i don't know
how to use the
camera hey you try it like come on just
[ __ ] get me out of here
because when you come off stage you're
in the [ __ ] you're still in a you
know
the heat of the battle head and then you
have to go immediately into politician
mode
and smile and shake hands and thank you
for supporting me and
but your head is still in [ __ ] you good
night
no well my thing towards the end was
just
give them such a great show that they
don't want to meet you like that's it
like just give them the best show that
they [ __ ] could have
the best show you could give and end it
there like i was doing theaters at the
end
and the theaters are telling me you
can't go outside because
we won't start the show on time we'll
nev we won't get you out of here on time
and it started bothering me for a while
but i also started realizing that my
second show
was a lot better when i would do meet
and greets after the first show
i would eat a bag of dicks the second
show because you're just talking for a
[ __ ] hour
you're answering questions people want
to ask you about what you said on
rogan's 800th episode oh yeah yeah
i don't remember what i ate for lunch
yesterday exactly
and you want me to repeat something from
[ __ ] a year ago i have no idea what
you're talking about
so that did get tough that's the good
thing about covert
that we don't take pictures anymore i
mean all that [ __ ] is gone you know
hello nice to meet you and move the [ __ ]
on but the pictures was getting
it was too much it's like i don't go to
dinner before comedy
there's a reason like when you go into a
town somebody always calls you and says
can i buy you dinner of course
what can we do lunch no we want to do
seven o'clock
and then they bring three people and
then it becomes a game of [ __ ]
jeopardy with the questions
and by the time you go to actually do
your 45-minute spot
you're burnt out from talking to dinner
i'm always trying to find something in
the moment
in the news in the day in the room
something
i could talk about right off the bat to
make my old [ __ ]
fresh and if you want to [ __ ] look up
before the show
we're going to be talking about this
like so what's new
what do you think about i remember i did
the last show in seattle before they
shut it down for coven
and uh yeah i had some friends it was
an obligatory okay they're they're from
bisbee so i have to go meet up with them
they're in town
and i everything they're starting to
talk to me about
this is what i'm going to open with on
stage say i don't want to talk to you
right now talk to me after the show
don't talk to me before a show because
i'm in my head trying to
every show i do i am [ __ ] stressed
out about
how like i'm always bored with my
material even if i wrote it and it's my
favorite joke a week ago
by day seven i it's [ __ ] boring yeah
i'm bored off yeah
so if you talk to me before the show
that's all that's in my head and i'm not
saying it till i'm on a microphone
no it's crazy that's people never really
grasp that
that there's so much more to just to
stand up
you know when i go out there and talk to
you for an hour that's an hour i'm taken
away
from me resting and getting ready for
the second show
so i would always feel bad i would
always go back to the whole
hotel room feeling [ __ ] guilty as
[ __ ] that
i didn't shake that hand i don't miss
that no more
yeah you've got feelings that you have
known for a while and sometimes
it's just a [ __ ] job sometimes that
[ __ ] smile on my face out there
is completely autopilot and i don't want
to hang out and just because i'm in
boston
doesn't mean i want to you know hang out
with [ __ ]
18 people i grew up with i sometimes
i just can't do it uh and then
people get pissed off and you lose
friends and then you go
uh those four friends i kind of lost in
1985 when i left massachusetts
uh anyway i want to talk to you
you're [ __ ] writing a book i want to
talk to you about your book
yeah it's been it's been a struggle i've
been trying to write it for eight
[ __ ] years
i finally broke down and got a writing
partner and she makes life a lot [ __ ]
easier
she lives yeah it's just listen i i was
just listening to episode 41.
yeah it makes life a lot easier
because i don't know what the [ __ ] i'm
doing but
i got like three or four books in my
head that i like to write
and this is the time to do them when
there's nothing going on you know
i wrote a nine show with a guy i don't
want to be on tv
but we ended up writing a [ __ ] little
spec script and whatever
i wrote what with him i don't want to be
on tv that's the last thing i want to do
is be on tv people don't understand
tv is the like the amount of work that
we
got into comedy to not have to do for a
living i don't want to work 16 hours a
day on
anything i want to go in i don't mind if
you want me to do a doug stanhope show
i'll do it but do me a favor shoot me
out quick
because after six hours i'm gonna start
[ __ ] around
and smoking dope and eating edibles and
i'm gonna forget my lines
and then you're gonna get pissed off at
me so before that [ __ ] happens
i'd rather you just shoot me out quickly
i don't mind going in at six i'll go in
at six
just get me off by one or two but to
stay there all [ __ ] day to do
one line at midnight i'm done with that
[ __ ]
that that stuff is done you know comedy
rooms like i said i don't know about
going to a [ __ ] airport i mean like i
can't see myself
at an airport right now right now today
maybe i feel a little different
yeah i i vastly it depends on when you
talk to me if you talk to me at eight
o'clock at night after several cocktails
i'm i'm big on projects and i want to do
stuff and then i
i wake up at [ __ ] you know 6 15 in
the morning with the dog wanting to walk
oh [ __ ] that i don't want to do any of
that
i wrote down a bunch of notes last night
of all these things
and then i wake up going nah i like this
laying on the couch [ __ ]
way more than all those projects i
remember
when the pandemic first hit and they
were just canceling months
remember in the beginning they would
begin
at the beginning i was the last show in
seattle
and they closed that down and i get this
is the routing i had was
seattle to baltimore to boston back to
san francisco for three days
and as i'm flying to each of these
places
she before the show [ __ ] the governor
comes on the tv
says no more crowds more than 250 people
magoobies let it slide they go well
we'll probably have a lot of no shows
anyway
we're 350 but it'll probably be 250 with
the no shows we did that show
i fly to boston the governor as i'm
landing
no more shows they cancel i fly to san
francisco
they go we're going into lockdown i got
my last flight
to vegas i wasn't even playing there's
just going to see hennigan the scotsman
and the [ __ ] governor comes on and
says okay
vegas is shutting down everyone has to
be out of their hotels tomorrow by noon
and then i you know there's just [ __ ]
dominoes chasing me of [ __ ]
governors shutting shutting everything
down before i get home
so yeah mark [ __ ] crazy
yeah [ __ ] science fiction like
everywhere i'm going it's getting worse
like i was making jokes in seattle i was
trying to
i was telling people to [ __ ] lick
their neighbor like a trust fall
i shook every hand i didn't take it
seriously whatsoever
that was like march 7th speaking of
seattle
do you remember when i drove you to the
gig in the trailer and it was snowing
when we had the dog
you wrote a bit about it that the dog
was holding you for support
do you remember i had a i had the
[ __ ] camper
and you came to me i opened up youtube
you remember doing new year's eve with
you when i was dating a christian hajj
oh yeah she was great i'm godfather
first son
that down in florida living it up down
there
and speaking about i said i i want to
apologize
uh because of the you know the me too
era
uh i did uh i did take a naked
photograph of you
and uh now i need to reflect and
apologize
i remember that picture i'm sure i still
have it somewhere in the crawl space
yeah you in front of bunk beds and uh
you know i understand now there was a
power dynamic
you were staying at my house i shouldn't
have put you in an
uncomfortable position just because you
had a giant [ __ ] [ __ ]
uh and i feel bad about that and if i
ever find that picture i'll post my
apology with the picture on twitter
i wish you do i i i felt so
empty and lost i almost joined vikram
yoga
after i got naked for you it was a
toss-up between vikram and scientology
that's how that's how [ __ ]
susceptible i was get the [ __ ] out of
here
i showed everybody my dick those days
everything you were just coming out of
the shower
get out your [ __ ] towel off i think i
even showed your mom my dick one day on
my balls at a comment at the comedy
store
and she were those those are some balls
because i did a one-man show and she
came with selena
and jody and gentry and marilyn martinez
was there
oh yeah and i'll never forget that i go
by the earmuffs what are you saying
and marilyn goes is that doug stanhope's
mother
oh my god doug i love him cause they
were both cats you know marilyn had like
nine cats
and then your mom had like nine cats so
god rest his soul marilyn and your
mother started talking
it was a [ __ ] great night who was
that [ __ ] uh
crazy neighbor girl that lived on the
same floor at curse on
in the corner uh the german girl
with her blonde girlfriend there's two
girls and yeah you i think you were
i think you were doing heroin with one
of them yes
the blonde one yeah i fought the tall
german girl
we had snow we had one a couple times
listening
it wasn't that i was into heroin it was
that she was hot she was another one
that took advantage of me
because she was hot and she gave me the
heroin and she made me do it doug
and then she made me eat a [ __ ] i felt
so [ __ ] violated
i've never felt this violated in my life
we'll start a support group
yes she made me snort heroin with her
and then she could eat her [ __ ] i just
i just i just thought of that because
the the [ __ ]
story that will never die is my joey
jingle
story i asked you when i was so [ __ ]
up on uh rogan's podcast
i did mushrooms going into his podcast
and then i started drinking and then as
the mushrooms are kicking in i go
oh i can handle some [ __ ] joe rogan
weed i don't smoke weed
and then i smoked that and i was [ __ ]
that was like like the
the drug scene in midnight cowboy
let me tell you something my feelings
got so hurt
i was so hurt that you said that guy
stole your [ __ ] jingle jaw
or whatever then people started calling
me joey jingles
and i'm like out of all the things i
stole in my life
i've been getting i've robbed [ __ ]
houses cars
i've put people in trunks of cars and
you're [ __ ] accusing me of a [ __ ]
jog
robbing a jaw full of coins i was i was
just high and i remember
thinking i wonder if j like i could i
remember it was like 1996
and i remember like who would just take
my change jar
and then i thought well because you know
the heroine i don't know
like when you hear about heroin you
think oh people go to depraved states
maybe he needed heroin money
and what what happened is right after
that came out
that same girl evan called me up and
said oh yeah that was uh
that was probably this guy ever she
brought a guy to my house when i was on
the road and he was like a sketchy
[ __ ]
street urchin guy and she's like yeah
i'm pretty sure he stole that
like well and i've i've said that but i
can't [ __ ]
i can't kill that story i can't kill the
joey jingle story
even though leave it sorry
it's already been [ __ ] whose cares
i've been accused of a lot of things i'm
a man of many accusations
but i never bought the heroine she
always bought the heroine
i forgot all about that you just brought
that up just now
she was beautiful she was yeah she was
remember i
like you have a image of someone in your
head
and you don't know why you do or don't
like them but i remember her saying
something really [ __ ] to me
uh which i probably took offense to
because it was accurate
but whatever it was i have no idea it's
weird when you look back and you go
i don't know why i don't like them but i
don't
i don't know what happened and they had
another girlfriend
that i started hooking up with they had
a redhead that was
kind of a chubby girl she was a plus
size model
and she was doing heroin so i started
hooking up with her for a while
her father owned two blockbusters he was
mick jagger's manager or something
business manager and he bought her two
blockbuster videos up in ventura
and she was just whacked out on heroin
too
i never said i was never buying it i
didn't even know where to buy it that
girl
would bring me up there and i'd do a
couple lines of coke
she'd give me a line of heroin then she
let me eat a [ __ ] that was it
that's that's the reason blockbuster
went out of business
yeah yeah hurt her drug abuse
and i still remember our nights at that
[ __ ] coaching horses
what a [ __ ] bar that was it was
incredible
and and we found it we found it when it
was an
actual dive bar that you were afraid to
go into nobody was ever in there
and then they [ __ ] dive bar man they
had the
old lady uh ginger or george ginger
ginger was the old lady bartender she
was like
throw mama from the train mama
yeah well you want another drink well
this isn't a bus stop
she threw a blind guy out for having a
dog and she wouldn't
listen to other customers explaining
that it's a seeing eye dog
i don't care the sign says no dogs
and so uh it was a dive bar because of
her
and then uh then they finally fired her
and hired a hot bartender and all of a
sudden it was the trendiest [ __ ] bar
on sunset
i just remember being in there with you
me day fulton
oh yeah maybe mitch i was
i bought some coke and silverlake it was
the best coke i ever bought in
california
here i am at the [ __ ] coaching horses
and i couldn't even talk i was sitting
at the bar with you guys you guys were
having a conversation
i couldn't even [ __ ] talk i still
remember that night
couldn't talk oh you you were
because because of the of the coke how
[ __ ] up i was i did not say a word
that's weird becker was always like that
becker who could never
shut the [ __ ] up in real life it was the
opposite he was so hyperactive but
you get him coke and he just sat there
i couldn't say over i was there i wasn't
there that night
but i remember going in another night
and seeing you there
and the girl had said that she just saw
again defenie had just left
with two broads like this had to be two
thousand
two thousand one maybe uh is it
gandolfini or tarantino
gandolfini all right because i know
tarantino was in there
uh uh fema was in there a few times
michael keaton i remember being in there
keith for sutherland
but back when it was really diving yeah
it was diving it was a real dive [ __ ]
bar that's why they'd show up there
because [ __ ] no one's in there
no you got to see what it looks like now
it's like a fancy [ __ ] restaurant
well it's the [ __ ] i've seen it it's
it's gone
it's gone for good it can't be that
[ __ ] and then
next door was a bookstore remember that
bookstore where you bought all the
acting books and [ __ ]
that [ __ ] that's gone that's gone
it's over
you know it's a shame that all those i
still remember playing tennis
with you at gorky park with mitch heads
and get i would get a nickel bag down
there
that was like the [ __ ] that was like
all russian run down there it was like
the russian mafia down there
selling nickel bags and we would play
and then me and mitch
would walk up to hollywood boulevard and
the stripper used to make us
[ __ ] iced tea suntee
that's a long [ __ ] time ago man
that's where hedgehog wrote that joke
i realized no matter how much i played
tennis i'll never be
better than a wall oh my god
yeah his first letterman he he did that
joking he used my name
i said i played tennis with my friend
doug
i think that's me that's me you still
miss him
[ __ ] yeah i miss him too i miss
all those guys i miss ralphie i miss i
still remember being in the coaching
horses with you
with brody stevens one night
and we hooked up with two broads i was
with abroad
and she had a girlfriend and i didn't
get laid but brody
got laid
i remember go ahead he had a
super unknown he had a volvo at the time
and he was playing super unknown by
soundgarden and i'm like
i need i need that cassette and i just
took it from him
and the next day he's like did you take
my super unknown cassette i'm like no
why would i take your [ __ ] cassette
that was the last time i was probably in
coaching horses
i i remember being in the coaching
horses this girl i had
uh banged on the road in iowa
i know it was iowa because that's i
couldn't remember her name so i just
called her iowa
she showed up in l.a and we went to some
bar
and then remember renee
this is when i was so in love with renee
that uh
i i couldn't land the deal and she would
always hang out in the coaching horses
renee my wife
[Music]
it's me and becker and iowa and we show
up at the coaching horses and renee is
there and i'm like oh [ __ ] this is my
this is the girl i've been trying to
[ __ ]
mail forever so i blew off the iowa girl
left her with becker and i'm going to
work renee and that girl gets pissed and
she goes and [ __ ]
becker to get me back i'm like yeah my
friend who never gets laid
you're gonna [ __ ] him oh i'm heartbroken
i'm heartbroken
so [ __ ] weird times doug doug i just
wanted to see you man that's it i wanted
to yeah yeah
i made my day on my last podcast like
you [ __ ] when you sent me that
i was like in such a depressed place
where you
like [ __ ] oh joey diaz [ __ ] yeah
that's
that's exactly what i needed in my day
was hey
were you gonna talk yeah i've been
really thinking about you a lot
ever since i left la just because you
got me started there
i would never i would have never gone
there if it wasn't for you
new year's talking me into going down
there you talked me into it
you were right you got to go down there
i mean wikipedia when we
started we both uh our first headliner
was uh matt woods was the first guy you
opened for
yeah pretty much denver he's on your
wikipedia page he can't trust it but
that was my first triple run
was with matt woods and i've as recently
as yesterday
i've quoted matt woods bits
really yeah i [ __ ] i don't know
whatever happened to him
and i hope he's out there but i could do
like that was a
like a two-week triple run with my first
headliner on my first like
serious road trip uh tour
and i could do his act to this day
[ __ ] you know
29 years later i could do his
experiments
about the squirrel yeah you have a joke
about a squirrel
you ever see a squirrel run or something
like that yeah yeah
uh but he had uh what was the one i
quoted
uh oh he's a yeah a
cop pulled me over on the way to the
show he said any idea why i
stopped you and i said yeah so would it
be
less windy while we talk
yeah he was he was the headliner on
stage
at the comedy works the first time i got
on stage
and i talked to him afterward and then
about
four years later he pulled me aside
and called me out and just you know he
read me the riot act of 1963.
he goes you know you can wipe the floor
with these guys
but you don't want to write jokes you
want to keep drinking and snorting coke
be my friend be my guest he goes but if
you ever put your mind to this you could
be really good
like he read me the riot act and i walk
to the bus station i'm like you know
what
i'm gonna go back and beat him up like
that was my answer
you know like some guy tries to help you
and i was so
[ __ ] up then i went to the bus station
and i go i can't believe that guy talked
to me like that
i had a white t-shirt on like just a
regular
white t-shirt with like a hooded
sweatshirt and he's like you were gonna
go on stage like that tonight
with a white t-shirt really that's why
he just read me the riot act and i went
back to beat him up but he wasn't there
and then i see him maybe
maybe five years later he's writing for
brian dunkelman
remember brian dunkleman yeah you know i
actually just uh uh
started talking to him again on twitter
i love that he just [ __ ]
shoulders his bad beat from american
idol and runs with it but go ahead
send him my love he's a good guy i was
at
him i was in a room called i forget
like in somewhere in l.a it wasn't like
it wasn't a comedy club it was just a
regular room
and matt woods came in and saw me blow
the [ __ ] room up
and i remember coming off the stage and
him going
that talk really helped you and i said
to him you have no idea
how close you came to getting a beating
that night you [ __ ]
and then we became friends and uh that's
it that's what life is all about buddy
but let's check in with each other in
about a month let's do this again
absolutely sir a pleasure you take it
over at work
oh [ __ ] yeah how's bingo doing
uh she's pretending not to be in the
background
okay send him my love tell her i love
her
hi baby hey baby what's happening you
sexy [ __ ]
i'm like in somewhere i was listening to
the whole thing
all right great to see you i love you
i remember one of those times someone
sent me oh joey diaz is talking about
you got to listen he goes
yeah i want to have him on my podcast
but he always shows up
with this like gaggle of [ __ ] he's
got a he's got a what are you not a crew
but what do you call it
like 19 people you show up with like 19
people deep
i got a little [ __ ] office in l.a you
know what i'm saying
i love you thank you over there i don't
want him to think i got a posse over
here
you're good you're good but i love you
and i'm happy i got to see you
and to talk about some old times and
thanks for all your help
because without you i wouldn't be here
so thank you brother
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah i love you very much sir
i love you buddy have a great week and
we'll talk soon
this will air on monday so get ready
yeah i'll tweet the [ __ ] out of it all
right i love you
stay black i hope you enjoyed that dog
that was uh
a great 50 minute talk just seeing him
did something to my heart it made me uh
grateful again uh it took away a little
bit
more of the anxiety and it was it was
just great to see him i haven't seen him
in such a long time
i know you joey jingle fans are happy
now you [ __ ] suckers
but uh yeah it was a great time i want
to thank doug
it was great seeing bingo uh and we'll
keep it at that like i said
you guys are sick of me for right now
i'm gonna give you as a week off
we'll probably get another zoom guest
for wednesday uh i love you
[ __ ] with all my heart stay
black
i love you and here's for a word from
our sponsors
all right i want to thank doug stanhope
but most importantly i want to thank you
guys before we go anywhere
i want to talk to you about something
the joint is brought to you by
on it listen whether it's the shroom
tech
new mood alpha brain on it is the best
supplement out there
why because i live on it i do my alpha
brain
cycles and i'm way better when i got
here i was a little
i couldn't put sentences together i went
on alpha brain
now i'm tip top magoo don't get me wrong
i'm still half [ __ ]
but alpha brain has helped me the new
mood is tremendous at night
i like this the protein chips i like the
protein bites
listen everything they have is
tremendous i can't do nothing to you
with the weights
but for supplements i'll get you 10 off
right now if you go to honor.com and
press in church c-h-u-r-c-h
i'm going to give you a ten percent off
and try it out
alpha brain powder tremendous side
tremendous
i have it upstairs i use it tremendous
the flavors are great
go to alex.com right now press in church
and get the party started remember if
you're the alpha brain you don't like it
call them let them know they'll send you
your money back and they don't even want
the product
that's a real company the joint is also
brought to you by
movement watches okay listen i love my
movement watch
they sent me the international medal the
international
element internal national waters because
like i told you in the beginning of the
show
i'm an international man of mystery only
a doctor wears a watch like that
and the shades look at that they call
dusk
dark and mysterious so you can't see
where you're looking you follow me
nobody knows nothing this is all brought
to you by movement watchers
they're just not a watch company anymore
they've expanded into blue light glasses
jewelry and more and i love everything
that they do
these movement guys are smart their
pieces look like they cost half a
[ __ ] million dollars
but since you won't they own the process
and do everything online
you end up paying a fraction of what
they'll charge at a real department
store
no middleman nothing nothing you save
hundreds
movement passes the quality on to you
and it's ships free
if you don't love it you send it back
it's all free
this all started with two college
dropouts that came up and shook things
up
they wanted fair prices new colors and
fresh designs
and now movement is an international
brand
way more than watches they've expanded
into blue light glasses
jewelry like i told you and more so do
yourself a favor
elevate your look elevate who you are
without breaking the bank join the
movement right now and get 15
off today right now today free shipping
and free returns i know it's movement
but you're going to go to mbnt.com
joey again that's mbmt
joey again mbmt.com
joey free shipping and free returns this
is what i'm talking about you want to
look sharp
spring is coming you know what i'm
saying you don't have to have long
shirts no more
you want to look like you're james bond
go to mbmt.com
joey right now and get the party started
i love you guys i'll see you back here
wednesday
tip top magoo ready to go i hope you
enjoyed the podcast thank you very much
for supporting us
there you go nobody got covered here
[ __ ]
so
you